[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream q a with lots of cats
drinking cream
on the back shelf yes that's what they
do
that's what what they do it's who they
are that's how they do
yep i really like that sometimes
they what
we're gonna get in trouble are we i
think i don't think so i think i think
we've crossed through that valley
we'll get in trouble but not for that
okay
um we have three questions from episode
66
then a question from the discord server
this week and then we will launch
into um
the questions from last hour before
moving on to the questions from this
hour
question one from last week why did
marsupials evolve to have pouches and
why are they mainly found in australia
the pouches because they're on the
marsupials there it is good no we're not
so the last night's thing that we did
yes bad bad
answers to bad questions wrong answers
to them that wasn't a bad question but
that was a bad answer it was a bad
answer yeah one correct answer here
is um that uh they don't all have
pouches
go on no that's all okay it's just true
it's true though they don't all have
pouches
right but now i'm not gonna be the one
to
spell out which parts of the clade are
pouchless
i don't i don't honestly remember all of
that now all right because i did i did
not do my research on this
just uh so why are they mainly found in
australia okay
so i i i can do that part if you like
you go
all right let's just let's let's break
this down we've got several parts of it
but
we probably want to try to go fight we
had so many questions this first hour
i'm gonna i'm i'm razer i'm laser
focused
and razor sharp you are um the answer is
this
you've got a problem that you need to
solve right the problem is
how do you gestate a comparatively large
endothermic creature one answer would be
to lay an egg
right laying an egg has certain
advantages you can leave the egg the egg
is self-contained
but it doesn't allow you to provision it
right so you've got to load everything
into the egg to begin with which is
dangerous
another version of this would be
internal pregnancy and if i can quote
you when you were internally pregnant
this is a really goddamn dumb way to
reproduce
awful awful it's really awful but like
if i at some point
i would be delighted to do an entire
episode on overparity viviparity and
wait for it
oh viviparity yeah i love this stuff the
the various selective pressures on
when to lay an egg when to have live
birth when to have an egg inside of you
that hatches right before you birth the
thing
amazing different selective pressures
most of which allows a person to talk
about lizards as well which is always
something i'm interested in doing but i
don't think this is the place because
if if we go back that far we're gonna be
here forever but when we do that one
that'll be the biggest dark horse
podcast
ever yes fine i'm interested in the
niche subjects
i know this but the point is okay you
got egg on one side
right lay the egg certain advantages
lots of disadvantages
you got internal carry it with you
everywhere
pregnancy right that has certain
advantages
certain disadvantages and marsupial is a
bit
in between right there's a
facultativeness to it so
you can birth the baby early so it is
not a threat to the mother and the
birthing process
the baby continues to function more or
less as if it is internal
in the sense that it latches on to a
teat and takes nutrients and grows in
the pouch rather than
uh in the uterus
like she can she can effectively have
three dependent offspring at different
ages at a time that's true
she can have a joey in the pouch she can
have a joey that's free floating free
hopping
if it's a kangaroo and uh and one still
in utero
and if you think about it it allows some
of the advantages of pregnancy
to extend beyond pregnancy a joey that's
capable of bouncing around on its own
can still hop on the pouch when you
gotta hightail it and get somewhere
quick
um so there are certain advantages
certain disadvantages the one thing you
don't want to hear but i'm going to tell
you anyway
is that it's all about the future and
for a mother who is being pursued
um by a predator she may in fact even
eject a
uh joey in order to save her own life
which sounds selfish but
her future children's that's the thing
if she's protecting her future brood
so the short answer is uh
it is one way of solving this
set of problems and it has advantages
and disadvantages like all of the others
um but uh like that and then do you want
to cover why it's in australia yeah
so um broadly speaking there are three
extant clades of mammals
there are the ones that i call the wacky
mammals at the base of the mammal tree
which include the echidnas
and the platypus which are egg laying
and then you have the two
big clades the placentals which we are a
member of and the marsupials and the
placentals i think are still an order of
magnitude larger in terms of specieosity
than
the marsupials maybe not quite but but
close and i think there are not even a
thousand species of marsupials and there
are
over 4 000 species of placental mammals
i think i believe so um i think it's not
quite
but doesn't matter um we're in the right
neighborhood if there are 5 000 species
of mammals at this point there are
well more than 4 000 of placentals i
think but
i'm not yeah anyway not not sure exactly
what the numbers are but
um placentals in direct competition with
marsupials
do better and one of the ways
we know that is that placentals involved
so
you had pangea and then it split into a
northern
lauraja and a southern gondwana and the
mammals already existed before pangaea
split and the
placental mammals were in the north in
laresia and the marsupial mammals were
in the south and gondwana
and so you have either extant or fossil
evidence
of placentals throughout all of the
modern land masses that
um that were gondwanan which is to say
australia
south america madagascar india australia
and antarctica even in like i actually
don't know if there's any fossil
evidence in antarctica but for other
stuff with gondwan and distribution we
know from ice cores in antarctica that
there is
that they were there and so there were
marsupial mammals in
south america and when south america and
north america slammed into one another
some many millions of years ago the
marsupials that were in the south
started heading north and the placentals
that were in the north started heading
south
and basically the placentals won and the
only thing we have remaining in terms of
marsupials in the new world the
so-called new world the americas
is a few possums like all within one
little tiny possum clear there's some
many
much more interesting possums in
australia and we've just got
like didelphus adelphade i think and
maybe maybe
maybe one or two others in south america
i can't remember but
um it's a small group small group tiny
group and basically
placentals have you know australia never
slammed into anything
and except for us in all of our hubris
and arrogance bringing stuff into
australia which yes indeed
um you know the placentals that we've
brought in are putting the marsupial
mammals that are endemic to australia at
risk
uh the marsupials are doing fine absent
direct competition from
placentals yep uh there are
some placentals natively on australia
though
humans now nuts yeah bats
that's it the whole flying thing it's
the whole flying thing you can just you
can
you can leave barriers that other things
just can't get across that's right
all right question two uh
two i don't know what that means two
asterisk speed media
um evolutionary view on impact
oh two times media evolutionary view on
impact of routinely listening to or
watching podcasts and classical music at
two times speed
advisable or not for young children
question mark
would we have young children listen to
podcasts on double speed is that the
question
uh podcasts um and classical music which
i find it fascinating that that's added
in here like i cannot imagine
listening to classical music or really
any music
at twice the speed that um that
it was intended to be listened to at
except that i actually
the story may be apocryphal but i
remember from when i was deep in the
classical music
uh scene as a as a child and and
teenager
um was it john philip sousa who
apparently wrote all of his music as
like dirges
and his wife came in and was like dude
speed it up
and she made them into these marches
that we're now familiar with
so sometimes composers get it wrong and
you know that again that may be an
apocryphal story
um but in general i would i would not
think that listening to music at twice
the speed that
um the artists themselves imagined would
do would enhance the experience or do
good things for your brain yeah
i would say music super bummer and
podcast just fine if you're an adult but
i
wouldn't yeah because the thing is
there's a lot of information
in like um cadences and things
and to the extent that you are going to
um be
developmentally impacted by what you
discover on podcast it's not just
you know factual content right so yeah i
would say
um what's the rush i mean for one thing
it's childhood
um so yeah i i think it's it it can't
help
um yeah i mean i guess the argument well
i imagine i can do more but
exactly i'm imagining that you know the
kids in the car is willing to listen
and the parent might be accustomed to
listening at two times speed because
they want to get through more content
and i would say if you can if if you can
bear it you know you pick your
your place where you're willing to have
more risk and less and all of this but
i would i would strongly suggest not
sorry i must have missed something in
the question the idea is the parent
is listening on double speed while the
child is in the car that's just my
that's
that's what i'm intuiting as a possible
context in which this would be relevant
yeah it'd be a little different because
it might actually allow a child to tune
out
you know if you're listening to podcast
content that your child is not going to
be interested in some level
breaking them free from it completely
might be a good idea and having it just
be
you know maybe i'm not sure about that
well definitely we can agree that
driving at double speed is probably not
safe
yeah so driving yeah i can't do it okay
um third question from last episode boy
doggy is interested in playing she wants
to go and play in the snow
is there a correlation between
pornography and the lack of masculinity
that's driving some of the madness in
our current political climate
thanks for all you do um lack of
masculinity i would say lack of
masculine maturity
yes there is a way in which this
pornography is
certain and at some point i am going to
go very much in depth on this topic
because i feel like there's a
um a huge amount of good to be gleaned
just by getting us all on the same page
about what the hell is going on
uh with men i feel like there's an
equally important what the hell is going
on with women conversation
and were you to file those two things
together you could almost just put them
on a bookshelf
but in any case
men have two reproductive strategies
porn is playing
to one of them and it's not the one that
makes good things happen on planet earth
so um yes
it's a very it's a good question and a
deep answer and uh stay tuned yeah
and you know we do we do a fair bit of
it in the book
which will be out in still way too many
months
um but you're talking about doing an
even more sort of
simultaneously slightly deeper and more
succinct dive elsewhere yeah
um okay the discord question for this
week so every week uh those of you who
are on discord uh some of you get
together and
i guess uh pose questions and then vote
on which one you want us to answer this
one we should call it the discordant
question go on so he does not yet know
what the question is guys just so
in case you weren't just i'm you know
i felt like we stripped a gear there so
brett says the discordant question
is yes you ready yeah in honor of
valentine's day would you tell us the
story of how the two of you ended up
together
we know that you met in high school but
two of you ended up together
uh oh god so the way it comes in i
always have to copy and paste several
lines and oh my goodness
um sorry i have to go back into my email
because this
some oh here we go okay in honor of
valentine's day would you tell us the
story of how the two of you ended up
together
we know that you met in high school but
when did you know you wanted to pursue
each other and how did that happen
uh yeah wow boy
are we going there discordant is what
you said yes
um all right well let me say uh for my
part
um i did not know right away it was like
30 seconds after meeting heather that it
was clear
that um that this was the right person
for me but it was also quite clear i had
been
um at an all boys school
for a critical period in childhood
development and it was going to take an
awful lot of getting past that before
any such thing was going to be plausible
so um
anyway so you've been in that all-boys
school from seventh through tenth grade
yeah and then you came to the school
that i've been at since seventh grade
at 11th we met in 11th grade yeah and i
was a shy kid so
there were people in the all boys school
that i went to
who did manage to figure out how to meet
girls and interact with them
i was not one of those boys and so
anyway suddenly
being invited to leave the all-boys
school as you were as i as i was
um and uh coming to your school was
a uh a kind of mental revolution all
all of its own but um
so anyway we became friends because i
don't know why we became friends i guess
[Laughter]
i honestly cannot figure it out to this
day to be honest i know why i
became friends with you i don't know why
you put up with it but
you did which is cool
[Laughter]
so one of the things that proves that he
didn't know anything about girls
is that oh yes um is that
um you upon finding yourself interested
in me
um decided that you would suss out the
situation by telling one of my dearest
friends how interested you were in me
not imagining
that she might share that information
with me somehow i think it did not cross
your mind
that girls talk either either
i didn't know a goddamn thing about
girls
or that was the result of some sort of
deep insight and here we are
and here we are that's the truth okay
well i have two more bits of this story
here and there's lots more
but do i want to be here you're the one
to call it discordant before even
getting the question wow
yeah she's interested in something here
um
one of the ways that you could tell that
i was really truly interested in
at that point um being close friends
with you
um was that we had at
the school's crossroads the crossroads
school for the arts and sciences
and um you were dr one of the things
that people used to do but apparently
doesn't really happen anymore
is that um once you have your driver's
license you can
basically pay other people's parents to
pick their kids up and take them to
school and so you
know they pay you sorry sorry pick up
there yes you get paid like you're
one of your jobs was that you were um
driving uh younger kids to school
and so you always had to be at school
for zero period
and i didn't have a zero period
but i always showed up at school for
zero period and a group of us and i
could still
name all of them but a group of us would
sit in the hallway
outside of history class i remember
because the history teacher would
occasionally come out and yell at us
you're making too much noise
sorry tom yes tom latest the history
teacher who
with whom we had no love lost because we
were too
rowdy in the in the hallway um i would
come and hang out with with you
and the three or four other uh their
friends
you know all of whom i had been we had
all been friends and then you showed up
and we're like
cool brett's here so um i didn't have to
be getting up 45 minutes early every
day to come hang out with you know you
and a few other people in the hallway
did i it does seem like very strong
evidence but i would not be aware of
that evidence
for years later i just assumed you had a
reason to be there like i did and
so never put two together but one of the
other little stories then
contributing to the evidence is that um
i having known for a while because one
of my friends told me that you had told
her
um had a boyfriend at that point
actually a boyfriend from that same
all-boys school that you had been
evicted from and um and you know a few
others along the way and
and you had a girlfriend in college and
at some point
close to halfway through college uh i
had
looked around and said you know what
i i know who i want to be with i know
exactly who i want to be with
and you were at that point on the east
coast and i was on the west coast we
were in different colleges and i wrote
you a
long letter telling you that i was uh
i was ready to try this out and
interested that was a great letter
and guess what his response was oh god
must we silence
no no i wrote so many response letters
so much silence it was the mailing of
the letters
that was that's the sticking point
because it was really hard to get one
really really right um anyway i
apologize for that yeah that was uh
excuse me and you have apologized before
now but you know we were asked
we were asked all right good well that
was very painful um
do you think we've answered the uh the
question there's a lot more to be said
so
we can we can go here more you know next
valentine's day next valentine or sooner
perfect okay first question from last
hour
um this is actually just a suggestion
but it came in it's such a high
monetary value i'm going to read it uh
with covet reporting and covet origin
story news spiking recently please
consider a conversation with chris
martinson
of peak prosperity your collective
knowledge and conversation on this
on the specific topics could be fruitful
for you both and enlightening for
your audience do you know i feel like
that name vaguely rings a bell but i
can't quite place it i'm not placing it
either okay
well i've got it in highlighted here and
we send such
suggestions to our assistant and
hopefully you
can have conversations on the regular
about who might be
worth talking to good all right
i don't know what this question means
but i'm going to read it
i want more epigenetic ecology
comparative epigenetics
epigenetic epidemiology but how who
epigenetic inheritance and speciation
right wow
so i support the enthusiasm but i'm not
sure what the
what so just like you i think the
question is like i want more of this
research i want us to know
more about what's going on at the uh
modification
of genetic inheritance well well well
what we don't know
we assume that the invocation
of the term epigenetic here is the
narrow molecular
version but it doesn't have to be
epigenetic means
above the genome and there's much above
the genome including culture
so um there's a question about
what the person is enthusiastic about i
think the most fascinating thing about
this realm is that there seem to be
um features of the
or rules of the epigenetic landscape
that transcend
mechanism so there is something about
culture and
molecular epigenetic mechanisms that
actually is
similar so um
where who how i i don't know where to
direct you
i do think it's um among the most lively
and interesting
of um the biological landscapes at the
moment
i am struck i saw a conversation
last week in which somebody who is
deeply ensconced in this field
reveals just how little was known back
when you and i were in college which i
remember
somehow there was a belief
in the power of genes that didn't make
any sense since all of your cells have
the same
genes there's obviously a whole lot to
be explained developmentally and
otherwise
that um isn't uh resident there but
the degree to which the discovery of
these mechanisms that allow one cell to
differ from another by transcribing
different genes etc
um the degree to which we have begun to
unlock
that set of puzzles is amazing and uh
anyway
it is the right place to be focused but
no i don't have any idea where to point
you
yeah yeah i don't either i'm afraid
what uh this is just this is easy for us
to point someone
what is the role of consciousness in
human evolution was it our genes
improving the species survival or did it
appear randomly
seems like it helped the rise of
civilizations but it also introduced
many self-harming behaviors for the
individual
uh so we this is something that we have
talked about and written about um
extensively the writing writing about it
is not yet out there in the world
um it's in the book that will be coming
out this year
um but among other places you i think
you've talked about it a number of
places
um but we talked about it in the talk
that we were supposed to give in person
at princeton
last april or may and of course had to
give over zoom but that means the upside
of that is that i think it's still
available
i think so too um so if you if you
google up princeton and our two names
maybe it'll come up unconscious maybe
it'll come up or but since we're still
affiliated with
well but since we're still fellows there
it might that might not be sufficient
but
uh robbie george was our intellectual
interlocutor
yeah but he's also the right but
nonetheless if you google those names
it's likely to come up especially if you
hit video on the
search but true um anyway
i would say i have noticed
that consciousness is the topic
that is most likely to tur to turn um
careful thinking people into spouters of
gobbledygook and i uh this has begun the
most
that's quite something the number one i
would say
that there is something about this topic
which causes otherwise logical people
to start saying the most amazingly
ridiculous things
so consciousness can't have been an
accident i think was
your term um
no it says was it our genes improving
the species survival
or did it appear randomly so okay so did
it appear randomly
the answer is all the components that
make it possible have to have appeared
ultimately there has to be a random
layer at the bottom back in time
but uh the fact is consciousness is
hugely goddamn expensive
right and complex complex and prone to
error right so what that says all of
those
facts tell you this was massively useful
to the species because all of those
downsides that it has to overcome
wouldn't have allowed it to to be
augmented if it didn't have this
tremendous benefit
so the real question is how and
i don't think we want to get too bogged
down here but i will say
i believe the reason that we don't
understand consciousness
that is to say that we don't have
agreement on what it means is that we
have misunderstood
it as an individual level phenomenon
which is very hard to explain
and what heather and i do that's
different
is we regard it as most likely a
collective phenomenon first and then
individual com
consciousness is an epiphenomenon of
collective consciousness
and the problem is because you can stick
a person
in a scanner and have them experience
conscious thoughts and figure out what
parts of the brain
light up right there's a bias towards
studying it as an individual
phenomenon which leaves lots of
paradoxes and so the upshot of this
is there is a hidden assumption
the assumption is that thing which is so
compelling
right individual consciousness we all
know that that exists because we
experience it but we don't know that
there's a consciousness
that exists between us because we can't
tap into it directly
that that bias in the direction of
individual consciousness
causes nothing to add up simply and
because it doesn't add up simply people
start grasping at ever more ridiculous
straws like
the particles themselves are conscious
and we're just tuning into it and all
sorts of other nonsense
yeah so the bias exists just to rephrase
what you just said the bias exists
uh you are arguing we are arguing um
in large part perhaps perhaps an entire
part
because it is easier to measure things
at the individual level than at the
interaction level than at the
then at the shared level and yet we know
that there are other examples of things
which only make sense in terms of
what is the combinatorial effect so you
know language
and just even you know just not humans
um but communication you know
communication requires both a signaler
and a receiver you can't talk about the
evolution of communication or any of the
communicative strategies that we talk
about over in
our neck of the woods evolutionary
ecology space and such um absent there
being both a signaler and a receiver and
doesn't have to be conscious
it doesn't even have to be intentional
by some people's uh
definitions of communication but it
requires those two things those two
individual sometimes they're not even of
the same species but you don't have
communication if there's just one
evolved in organism and so this argument
is actually not so
so out in left field as it might seem
because there are things that we know
require more than one individual to
understand them from an evolutionary
perspective
this is a great way of conveying this i
think yeah i'm not sure actually
i know we haven't done that in the book
but i think it actually that this
analogy
works i think it works and part of why
it works is
it's news to nobody that speech is not
about the speaker right because we all
are the listener also and so because you
can tune in on both of those things
nobody's confused about this
the thing about consciousness is if you
say consciousness the purpose of it is
actually
for me to say um you know
you know what if we took um you know the
sail
from a windsurfer and put it on a large
skateboard right
that's an idea that i can convey just by
vibrating the air molecules between us
and there's a good chance that if i had
you say if i said okay now can you
sketch
what i just said you could sketch it out
and we would know that i had
successfully conveyed this abstract idea
right between us so the point is
the language is obviously an emergent
phenomenon
consciousness stands every chance of
being an emergent phenomenon but we only
have
the one side of it right so um because
of that
the bias or you know in other words
i know that you probably have a picture
in your head
of a windsurfer sale on a skateboard
because i intended to put it there and
you and i share a language and so it's
possible to do that
i can look at my picture of that thing i
can't see your picture of that thing
until you put it on paper
so the point is the asymmetry here or i
could use language right back at you
you could right but um
the the asymmetry between the personal
experience of consciousness and the
inference that we have about somebody
else's consciousness
is so different that it's unlike
language
right you know you and i speak english
approximately equally well
and batting stuff back and forth is a
very simple process
but you know to be honest you know look
at the dog
how conscious is the dog it's very hard
to know
right i have the sense that the dog is
substantially more conscious than the
cats
i don't mean smarter but more conscious
but it's very hard to establish if
that's the case because
you know we can't play that game we
can't tell her things and have her draw
them or anything like that
um so she would love to play that game
oh she would love to play
any game that we wanted her to play
that's the nature of the dog
yep okay so anyway
uh yeah i think that's a that's a good
way of pointing it out the emergent
thing is the thing
and you know imagine the absurdity of
trying to figure out what language is
for if all you did was look at people
speaking
right if you didn't understand that
there was a listener yeah like well what
is the point of that behavior seems
mm-hmm and yet i mean we obviously could
and have in the past and presumably will
spend lots and lots more time on this
but i'm reminded actually of
sort of you know one of the exceptions
that kind of proves the rule of what
you're saying i recall a conversation in
a class i was teaching years ago
with a linguist and it was the class
called the evolution of communications
two-quarter program in which i was
mostly talking about non-human
communication and she was mostly talking
about
language but we of course were were
interleaving and it was a seminar with
both both sections and somehow we got on
the subject
of cat calls and
um one of the young women in the class
said you know i just don't i just do not
get it
like how often does that work like how
often
does a dude make an obnoxious sound at
you on the street get you going
home with him like i don't know of
anyone who would ever who would ever
respond this way
and um another student um
i'm just i'm not gonna name him um
but but do you know you know who it is
said i think completely correctly and he
said it i'm glad he did
exactly before i was gonna say it he
said yeah but
often and this is not someone who would
ever call anyone i just i just
know this for sure he said often the cat
calls aren't for the woman
that's not who's being communicated with
the dude who's cat calling on like a
construction site or something is often
communicating with the other dudes
like that's who the communication is for
it's not actually
about uh the successful completion of a
sexual encounter as a result of a gross
move on the street that makes a woman
feel less safe
right it's about um still you know
inappropriate and we all
we all i hope all of us you know wish it
wasn't happening
but it's about a way of establishing
rank between the men
yep um in that case i also wonder if
there's not just a distortion that comes
from the big anonymous society and if
the cat call would be toned way down
in a normal you know township and
well one of the other guys on the crew
would be like that's my sister
yeah don't do that yeah um i just wanted
to add one last thing
it occurs to me that there's actually a
hint
of this failure to grok based on
seeing only one side of the interaction
in the history of
the study of echolocation so
you'll remember because we've talked
about it before that echolocation
was first understood in animals when
griffin don griffin accidentally
he was an undergraduate at harvard at
the time and he accidentally
went to talk to a physicist and he put a
cage full of
bats down on the desk and it went
the ultrasonic detector went crazy there
because the bats were echolocating and
he put two and two together but
hundreds of years earlier an italian
guy who i think that's the kind of
serendipity that could never happen now
you don't you don't just walk into a
physicist's office with a cage full of
bats as an undergraduate right
and i mean it was a whole different era
and don griffin's a great guy and it was
a really wonderful story the right guy
made the discovery anyway he's super
intelligent and
has contributed a great deal since then
but anyway the
couple hundred years earlier i believe a
an italian guy named spallanzani i think
he maybe in any case he was a naturalist
who was trying to figure out how
uh bats navigate in the dark and he got
close
right he ran some experiments
and he demonstrated that it was their
ears not their eyes
and he did that by doing things like
plugging their ears
and he found actually the bats if he
plugged both ears they actually i think
did okay
and if he plugged one ear they didn't
right and the the way he tested whether
or not they were able to find their way
in the dark was by measuring
their weight right so he would plug
their ears and then recapture them and
see if they'd lost
weight the idea of being if you know so
anyway
he did that and then so he's got all the
pieces of the puzzle they were
navigating with their ears somehow but
he wrongly concludes
that what must be going on is that
objects make noise
and the bats are tuning into it right
and so the point is he's got the one
side of the thing but he can't see that
there's a good bat
is emitting sounds that he can't hear
yeah that's so good so incidentally you
were right it's lazaro
spanzani um lived in the 1700s
died in 1799. so anyway i think it's a
it's a
perfect indicator of how you can go
wrong because you're only seeing half
the interaction and that the real thing
is the emergent
space between and that that's what's
going on with consciousness yeah
yeah that's that's good we should we
should remember this yes
it'd be great if we should record it and
then
i don't know we can put it into the
world yeah people can remind us
excellent
um where were we ah that was the
consciousness question markets can't
solve everything
how much is this i don't know what this
question means how much is the species
average lifetime the limiting factor
here might market failure be a function
of the participants of its participants
probability of being alive
to realize their investments profits and
costs
yes 100 actually and the way i
tried it the way i say this i'm not sure
this is the best way to say it maybe
there's some better way okay
um but the
individual is a description
of the limits of your capacity to
actually
affect your genes well-being
going forward so in other words
you actually selection doesn't care more
about whether
you're in the next generation than it
does five generations down the road
but the point is your ability to affect
your genes presence of the next
generation
is vastly greater than your ability to
do anything in the present
that will affect how many of your genes
are around five generations later and so
your focus is tuned to that over which
your ancestors had
influence and which mattered to fitness
um so the point is we now live very
different
lives and we now have the ability to
have effects
that are vastly greater at much greater
scale we can do things
at industrial scale that pollute oceans
and atmospheres and we can do things
that have
affect many many generations down the
road
and we have not had our perception
retuned for that so our sense of self is
at the wrong scale
self is really about lineage but it's
been limited down
to that part of the lineage that
actually you have influence over rather
than
the modern version which is actually you
could kill off the lineage you could
make decisions now that two generations
from now
will end humanity and you shouldn't that
should be every bit as important to you
as not
stepping in front of a bus yeah um so
anyway yeah we're in need of
it's another downside of senescence
well yes now there are upsides to
senescence too
of course but um people don't see it
that way in part because they're so
obsessed with their individual nature
and they don't understand that really
they're part of a lineage and that the
what matters what should matter is the
well-being of lineage going forward and
yes you do get a delicious little
slice where you get to be you know
conscious and
coherent in the middle but that's not
the point of the exercise
yeah what do you guys think about this
simple rubric
sex equals bedrock gender equals clay
also is random mutation really random
and if not should we ditch the term
mimicry
i am inexpressibly grateful to you both
that was a lot of questions yeah who was
that i don't even know
uh the person is called we haven't met
okay um so let's let's let's try this
one at a time
the simple rubric sex equals bedrock
gender equals clay
um yeah i mean it works i don't think
it's the it's the i don't think it's the
most
uh helpful that i've heard obvious pun
bedrock i mean i'm not gonna make the
pun but
i mean you see it right i don't know
all right sex equals so which sex do
they mean do they mean
sexual interaction or do they mean
sexual reproduction
like sex is in sex is binary and gender
is strongly bimodal
it's a sex gender comparison right
um yeah i agree with you i think you
could you could wrestle something from
that but i think you know
we what we have said and i still think
it's the right way to do it
is um that gender is the software
of sex yep and that this is really
how it works and why it's more flexible
and all of those things
yeah yeah the i guess both the sort of
soils ecologist and ceramicist in me
um don't quite like the the clay bedrock
thing doesn't quite work because both
exist without the other sometimes but
um sometimes is underlaying a sandy soil
or a loamy soil not a clay soil and clay
can of course exist without bedrocks
i think i just figured out what they're
getting at though okay the point is
they're not really talking about it
being distributed
in a strata they're talking about
just simple malleability rock changes
slowly over time
clay can change more quickly okay in
that regard yeah i agree
yeah that's fair but um software
versus hardware is probably um more
useful yeah it has more
more dimensions to it um okay
40 minutes well we've only just barely
gotten into this anyway we're going to
keep going a little bit
also is random mutation really random
and if not should we ditch the term
mimicry
so that's actually that's yeah the
second question doesn't hold off
but we should probably speed up i don't
think the place to attack this
is the randomness of mutation there is
some level
at which we can make arguments for
things other than random mutation
in other words even just the rate of
mutation is
malleable right by moving things around
the genome we can adjust how frequently
they mutate
so that is in some sense a non-random
process
there may even be examples and there is
some evidence for places in which random
is not exactly
or which mutation is not exactly random
but by and large
random mutation is not the problem with
the model the problem with the model
is the way in which design space is
explored
and so i have as we've talked about on
the podcast before
i've gotten into trouble by proposing
something i call explorer modes in which
selection is more systematic than random
at searching design space
for useful adaptations i believe this is
essentially certain to exist
that there are many examples
consciousness being one
but the point is that model
in which design space is searched
non-randomly is compatible with fully
random mutation i'm not saying right
that there is nothing non-random in
mutation but i'm saying you don't need
non-randomness in
mutation in order to get a supercharged
evolutionary process
yeah and that non-random search is um
epigenetic at least censulato yes
it may be potentially sensory stricto as
well epigenetic sensors
um and then if not should we ditch the
term mimicry
which you know i think selection
selection
works over here to find a similar form
um regardless of exactly what the random
distribution of randomness or
non-randomness is so i i feel like
that's a bit of a non-sequitur yep
i agreed with regards to your hypothesis
of screen time and autism
would we expect to see a similar
correlation from prolific book reading
or tv watching
why or why not seems like these also
detract from our evolved social cues
um so tb watching yeah it's a screen um
i mean i guess i don't i i we never
meant
i at least didn't mean to suggest that
putting your kid in front of a
like an iphone screen was gonna be worse
than
parking them in front of a tv using the
tv as a babysitter
um book reading is different because
it's it's not pretending to be the
entire complement of human being now you
know brett and i fall
out a little bit differently in terms of
what we uh think that the
actual risks of um of especially early
reading is
in fallouts or predictable ways um
i think some semi yeah okay you know
there are physical risks
to your eyes for example and then there
are also
risks about um this it's a
fire hose of information and
misinformation
uh pointed at a brain that may not know
how to sort the two
and you know you say as someone who for
a number of reasons
didn't read much as a child and i who
had that
who who asked for all the fire hoses you
dealt well with the firehouse all the
time
um yeah as as in part a result of that
but also spending a lot of time outside
and getting a lot you know i just saw a
lot of the world as well and experienced
like tactilely and sensory a lot of the
world as well
i was able to to a large degree i think
quite effectively parse the various
poses of information and figure out as
such you know now
am i think better able than many many
people to actually
quickly assess a lot of streams of
information coming in in text
like that not that no way yes maybe even
though it comes in on a weird source
that sort of thing
but i don't i don't think that's really
where this question is right so i mean
that's
why i said it's not regardless of what
where you and i fall out in terms of
what we think the risks of early
a lot of book reading might be i don't
think um
i don't think that prolific book reading
is you know anywhere close to the kind
of danger that we are positing for
young children watching human and
humanoid faces that look like they could
respond but then do not respond to the
child engaging
is there you know because you know if
you're reading a book
you may really want to engage with the
characters but there's a level of
abstraction
um that that hope the the book itself is
like holding you
at a distance in a way that screens do
not appear to be doing at least the
younger you are the more likely you are
to be confused by it
yeah i think i would i would say the
same thing but i might push it even a
little bit
farther and say the mechanism of the
book
is a safety mechanism right
the book may be trying to conjure things
that are plausible
in your mind but it does not pretend in
the same way that the screen does
and that the screen pretend to be those
things it doesn't pretend to be them
and that basically what we have is a
market solving the problem
of how do we make the people look ever
more realistic with no thought about is
that a good idea
to put children in front of something
that's that realistic and
does not interact it's a one-way
interaction so in fact it's almost
the mirror image of the consciousness
question we were dealing with
um a couple questions ago because in
some sense
it seems like something with an emergent
consciousness connection to you and it
doesn't work like one
right but my point would be whereas a
book like i
i can't mistake this for another human
being right it's very obviously a book
right and there's you can't for one
minute mistake it is anything other
um what i would argue by the way i
should say this is not our hypothesis
about autism and screens the part of it
that is our hypothesis
is so the hypothesis that screens are
doing it that's something about parking
kids in front of screens comes from the
study about
weather and its correlation with autism
which suggested that people who were
like kids who were likely to be in front
of screens more would be more vulnerable
the part that we're adding to that is
here's why that makes sense
you're learning to interact in a
emergent
cognitive way and then somebody puts you
in front of something
that has many of the components but it's
missing the key one which is that it's
not reacting to you
and that would do it so what this
predicts if it's true
is that black and white tvs
better than color tvs now there's no
such thing as a black and white tv
anymore
but there used to be commonly and the
point is
there's a bit is it black and white or
is it color the black and white tv
maybe kind of looks like people at night
sorta so it's maybe not perfect
but probably if you put a
yellow filter on a tv right
so that the child knew oh those are the
yellow filter people they don't interact
with me um
the people in normal color do this is so
i mean this is so
so good and in fact you know we employ
these sorts of rules in other places too
and like this this is this is a useful
thing to do
in life is that if you want to
be able to do something that might not
be optimal for you
and you want to be able to discriminate
between these two conditions which
otherwise might seem really similar and
learn to behave one way under one
condition another way under another like
find a bit that you can flip
yep and you know obviously before you
even said yellow filter i was thinking
of what we do with ping pong
right where when we're rallying before
we start playing a game now
we play with an orange ball and um yeah
i
i i love to hit it no matter where it is
right really see if you can get it just
see if you can get it and let it go
because you'll win a point
exactly and so um since we actually
started doing that i've become
better at not hitting the balls that are
out when we're playing with the white
ball even though i find it much more fun
to do so like sometimes i do it anyway
but
i'm i my there's something that like
goes what
white game white ball means we're in a
game orange ball means we're rallying
um slightly different you know just so
was just a bit flip that was a
hypothesis that that would work
and we bought two different co yeah yeah
my thought was i'd like
i don't if we're not if we're just
rallying i want to be able to chase
stuff down
but i don't want to mess up my game so
anyway
turns out it works it does which is cool
and i want to draw one other connection
here
um so you have described
um sexual autism
a sexual autism of the current moment
now
i think you have connected this to porn
yeah and i want to draw the full circle
here
because the point is all right sexual
autism having
nothing to do with actual artists right
right having to do with a it produces a
kind of set of beha i'm arguing that
porn we are arguing the book that
that that especially watching porn
is going to produce a set of behaviors
that is going to render people
less able to read and less caring about
emotional states
with regard to sexual interactions
that is somewhat analogous to the
difficulty that autistic people have
in reading and responding to emotional
states right without
without claiming that uh you know
autistic people are more likely to have
this
have this or like it's i'm using the
term i actually went to the clinical
definition of autism and went like
actually the description of how many
people men in particular
are engaging in sex now in this porn
rife society um seems to really over in
the sexual sphere
map onto this like dsm clinical
diagnosis of autism right and so the
the connection i want to draw is you've
got
men whose some large
fraction of their sexual experience
is now screen based and not realistic
because
you've got these basically corporations
looking to deliver
them what they will spend money for so
basically if the state of being turned
on
is frequently accompanied by unrealistic
human interactions that are designed for
one party with no
interaction with another party right
then the point is
it results in completely wrong lessons
being learned about the way people
interact
sexually which then get imported into
actual real bedrooms with real people
with whom you ought to be really
communicating
and so the point is this may actually be
just literal yeah right
it may be that same developmental break
um where the screens are realistic and
compelling and that's
misinforming the mind as to what a
particular kind of interaction
is and you know like that yeah
yes if
so this is two questions um from the
same person although i'm not sure
they're directly related
if the extinction of the irish elk due
to huge antlers
is an example of sexual over-selection
leading to maladaptation what are other
examples
in humans question mark and more on
sexual selection leading to
maladaptation
if we are not optimized for a new
environment should we play it safe and
only have ugly mates and kids
all right i'm struggling with the irish
elk and whether or not there is actually
compelling evidence i don't know
distinction is the result of the
impressive antlers i do not know that to
be true i don't know the irish elk story
that well
and um i don't know when and so like i
without knowing when i don't know if
this is a viable hypothesis at all
but um if if the when of the extinction
of the irish elk
was after humans were in ireland then
that giant iraq
uh may well have just made them easier
to hunt yeah that is you know that's
downstream of sexual selection having
made that giant iraq but
right but if it evolved before people
were there which it most certainly did
yeah and then it's a novel right it's a
novel selected for us
here's the reason i i sort of uh doubt
the connection that is being hinted at
here okay
is that that rack of antlers
comes with a extreme polygenous
mating system the disadvantage does not
flow to the females who don't have it
therefore all that is necessary for the
species to go from one moment in time to
the next moment in time
is for there to be enough males to
fertilize all the females that is to say
even if the males are massively more
vulnerable because of those antlers
which they
almost certainly are it doesn't adjust
the species likelihood
of going extinct because what you need
is females to be fertilized and it only
takes a tiny number of males to do that
so
um yeah although you would expect a sort
of a constant bottlenecking pressure
if a lot of the males were getting
picked off by predators because they
were more susceptible
well i mean unless the hobbies sahabi
applies here and
they're just they're doing brilliantly
despite the handicap i think
the the thing is you'll you'll get
whatever the populate down to a very
tiny percentage of the males
which is not rare in these systems
anyway and even to the extent that it
was what we've seen
time and again with these near
extinction events where
a population rebounds as a result of
human protection of like elephant seals
or otters
is that we just get this inbreeding
thing
wrong inbreeding is very bad early on
and then it exposes all of the
deleterious recessives to selection and
so the point is it actually
cures the system of the very recessives
that are the hazard
so so i'm not too worried about it in
the irish help case i i'm not actually
worried about it either because i know i
said a sort of a constant low-grade
bottlenecking without
actually saying what i think you heard
me say about it like going you know
repeatedly down to close to extinction
because
if you know if the female elk don't have
the antlers at all which i think they
don't
and there are a few males um you know
you've actually got
more than 50 of the population that's
still in the gene pool you're producing
so it's so it's not it's just it's just
about
what i said was a bottleneck in you know
it's a restriction of the gene pool
um that isn't down to anything close to
extinction level
restriction right and of course that
bottlenecking
um at some point i will
reveal the version of sexual selection
in which this all makes sense where that
bottlenecking is in fact the point of
these systems and it has to do
with females
engaging in a selectivity that is not
nearly so nonsensical
as um silly flighty females
right yeah it's about something that we
can't see very easily but it's there
nonetheless
yeah good um
thank you for everything interweb mama
haying and papa weinstein
i am a beekeeper in texas i am curious
if your thoughts on the honeybee
presence in north america in regard to
their impact on other pollinators here
well if i understand the story of
honeybees in north america they are in
fact
invasives from asia i think that i mean
that that's
implied without the specificity the
geographic specificity in the question
right it's mellifera i believe
and i can't see my screen um
where are they from you can keep talking
so the question really is how long have
they been here if you and i have the
right story about this
it says uh well just you know just
wikipedia western honeybee or european
honeybee
um so i i don't know if you're right if
it's asia or
these guys are right um but it's europe
but either way
with human assistance western honeybee
now occupies every continent except
antarctica
yeah so let's put it this way
i think this is the standard story of an
invasive
the impact on other pollinators was no
doubt devastating the
impact on flora that is to say plants
was probably pretty
radical but at this point the ship has
so long sailed that this is effectively
now our natural
pollinator and we ought to defend it as
such
and the other thing that i would say is
they're actually the um
[Music]
uh the harm of invasive species is one
of these
under appreciated effects of humans
that the devastation that comes from
invasive species is massive but in this
case
we have something rather different than
we see in the cases that you and i have
mentioned on the stream before
of eucalyptus which is devastating
parts of california devastating the
andes
or english ivy which is devastating the
pacific northwest and
other places these things drive out
native species and do not tend to
contribute very much in terms of habitat
in other words they create a kind of
empty forest
phenomenon because very few things eat
eucalyptus or
english ivy on the other hand the
honeybee is obviously playing a very
positive role with respect to
pollination in a lot of plants so it may
have driven
diversity down by competing with other
pollinators
but it is doing some of the very heavy
lifting in these ecosystems anyway and
so
i don't know it's possible that
ecologists have two different categories
of invasives like evil invasives and
contributing invasives but in this case
i would say
were we you know were we faced with the
initial habitat and its initial
pollinators we ought to keep the honey
bee out yeah but now that the honeybee
is here we ought to protect it because
it is effectively our native pollinator
now
yep and i will just um if you put up my
screen for a moment zach
the animal diversity web adw out of uh
university of michigan museum zoology
uh is a great source for um questions
on particulars on animals especially at
the higher level clades but in this case
actually this entry on april
liverpool was written co-written by
george hammond i was a friend of ours in
grad school
who were in grad school with george um
and
um and therefore often these individual
level species accounts on adw
are written by undergrads as part of
some
you know biology for beatnik's course or
something that their professor assigns
them and it's not always clear
how well it's done given that george is
an author on this i mean i know this is
you know probably decades old at this
point
um but i trust this initial assessment
geographic range apis malifa is native
to europe western asia and
africa and human introduction to other
continents started in the 17th century
uh and and like that so yep
there we go so there you have it um
here we go greetings from norway is
there some
evolutionary aspect of male pattern
baldness and are there some cultural
differences for this phenomenon and
what's the best treatment
for it it seems to be huge in
scandinavia i will say actually that the
question
actually reads is there some
evolutionary aspect of male pattern
baldness
which i think we should address on a
separate stream yes um
right with eagle pattern baldness which
is uh my favorite but
um this is a really good question
there i think the problem is this you've
got two things tied up here
one is it there is pretty clearly a
senescent component and the question is
is the pattern
the result of senescence it is just the
failure of some adaptive state which is
having hair on the top of your head
or is the pattern and adaptation of
itself in other words is it a
modification
of the senescent failure in some way
that has benefits
and you know at some level what you
ultimately need to do is figure out what
the adaptive purpose of hair on the top
of the head
is and why it might be altered over time
all right there's a thermal argument
there is a
uv protection argument and frankly i
don't know where any of
i don't frankly even know if there is a
literature in which this is well
addressed um i don't know why we've
retained hair where we have
yeah yeah i mean certainly some of it is
sexual some of it is pheromonal
pheromone distribution
and such yeah probably not on the top of
the head
yeah um so anyway i think i think a
deeper dive needs to be done
on okay why is the hair there in the
first place what would the natural state
of it be presumably dreadlocks
would be the thing which you know
there's lots of you know hey look if you
if dreadlocks are the natural state i
don't know it's on the top of the head
no that's true
but i think it's kind of i mean i guess
maybe before
scissors before blades before
before metallurgy um i have i
have no idea i like i don't know what
length hair stops growing in different
human populations
yeah well anyway let's take it to be
something like dreadlocks okay and
something like dreadlocks
um would serve a couple of purposes very
likely
one would be thermal another would be um
cushioning the i mean basically a helmet
seriously i think i know you are yeah
the head is very vulnerable
um you know our giant brains make it
looks more than just
thick hair yeah i think so because i
think the
the thing about dreadlocks is the hairs
are multiply inter-linked
and you know what we do to hair is kind
of weird
separating out all the strands and
there's just a lot less cushioning there
um i have the feeling i've just said
something that's going to get me
canceled
i don't think anything i think this is
maybe the farthest into like adaptive
arm waving stories that i maybe have
ever seen you go
all right yeah good hey you are not
prone to them it is a
hypothesis and it makes certain
predictions one
is to otherwise similar people in an
otherwise
similar accident propelled at high speed
into a wall
and there are a lot of accidents i i'm
on the what could go wrong channel let
me tell you there are a lot of things
that can go wrong
and the question is is it likely to be
less serious if you have dreadlocks than
uh you know hair that you've separated
all the strands and i would say
almost certain to be true another
prediction of the hypothesis would just
simply be
that we could measure the force
absorption you could just experimentally
measure it but i mean if you
if you're arguing for the original value
of hair
yep we're talking about african
populations
um probably not thermal well and we're
not talking about dreadlocks versus you
know hair that looks like mine where
you're separating out all the strands
you're talking about
very tightly coiled hair um that it
seems to me
would provide more of a cushioning value
than like my hair
even your hair would so i just i don't
think that's the right and i i think
you've created a sort of a straw man
comparison but i sort of feel like
you're you're you're just
i don't see that this is a this is uh
this runs counter
okay all right if you've got hair that
would be playing that role a kind of a
cushioning
role well you got hair that would play
that role in the ancestral form
and then presumably it would continue to
play that role
on a lot of planet earth prior to modern
hair
care so it all seems consistent to me
but anyway basic point is hey that's a
hypothesis it makes predictions
yeah i mean but there's other stuff
there which is to say you know i think
um
you know hair belonging to people of
african descent is more easily
turned into dreadlocks i believe than
hair belonging to people of
east asian or european descent is that a
challenge
sure okay i'm on it great
[Laughter]
you need to switch oh my god guys there
were so many good questions here though
okay wait let me just get like three
more quickly then we'll switch i promise
a sec
i was going to share a joke about
bibliographies but you probably won't
get the reference
terrible um if evolution were to rerun
from the beginning on earth would you
expect sexual dimorphism in the form of
small zippy gametes versus large mobile
gametes to evolve
if not would you expect sexual
reproduction at all yes absolutely
anisogamy which is what that's called
having two distinct forms would evolve
um if i wasn't trying to race through
these now i'd put up a
cool graph sort of describing it from
yeah but absolutely evolutionary
but uh yes we would expect to see it uh
yeah
um okay one more and then we'll move to
the next one and we will get back to
some of these
next week um i'm from texas and was
outside trying to save my plants from
the freeze
when my neighbor came outside to tell me
this weather is global warming and biden
will help us
any truth to that statement i'd like to
respond kindly well let us know when you
see him
biden or the neighbor um so that's i
mean that's two
that's two claims right um and uh it's
really hard to assess
either of them um the freeze that you
are getting right now
is due to global warming we can't know
that you know with individual weather
events we can't we
can't attribute to much longer scale
climate climate change um but over time
you know they they add up and they start
to look like climate
um and then and biden will help us
biden will increase the likelihood of
our participating in
the collective governance exerted by
nations i wish i had the sense that he
just was being advised by anyone who
knew what they were doing
well you know the fact that we will now
sit down at the table
is good what we will do at the table
probably the usual corrupt garbage and
it will you know be a drop in the bucket
and it will not take advantage of any of
the opportunities that would
actually leverage the climate
predicament
for the opportunity that it provides
um that's right okay so i don't have a
line here i'm gonna see if i can figure
out
i should probably be able to figure it
out zach um
yeah i see that
um
okay when yeah
when daniel schweichtenberger talks
about creating a human collective
intelligence do you think this means
generating a new kind of consciousness
and would we individual humans and this
consciousness be able to communicate
somehow or would it be like us trying to
talk with ourselves
if possible what kind of signals could
we expect to receive
from the ci i love the podcast
um i don't want to speak for daniel but
i have the sense
also sorry can you elaborate more on the
concept of exploring design space as you
have mentioned when talking about both
evolution and humans
sure i can do that quickly but um
i think what daniel is talking about is
something that's more mundane
than what you're imagining right we are
already
involved in some kind of consciousness
it's very haphazard and it's very
polluted by some of the things that we
allow to shape
the exchange of ideas in other words we
know that our collective
consciousness has tech platforms
exerting
influence over what you can and can't
say and who can say
what and you know in interspersing
advertisements and all of these things
that pollute our collective thinking
so the question is can we do it better
and if we do it better
it will feel a lot like there are shared
assumptions the way
you know until five minutes ago the west
was pretty much in agreement
that liberty was a good thing that
everybody deserved it
you know these sorts of things that's
what collective consciousness feels like
is like you don't have to you walk into
a room
and there's a pretty darn good chance of
the person you're about to sit down with
and exchange the first words ever
is going to have a shared sense that
racism is bad opportunity is
good that um you know being healthy is
desirable
right like that sort of thing is what
collective consciousness looks like and
we're just in a much
tougher predicament generating it so
facilitating it so it turns into
something higher quality
is very much an important objective but
i don't think
it's some i don't think it would feel
like something radically new it would
just feel like
you know people on average weren't as
confused as they are now
um did you get the exploring design
space piece in there
no i didn't exploring design space is
pretty simple
imagine you are some kind of creature
that there is some opportunity for a
creature that isn't exactly like you
and the question is can you get from
here to there
one of the things that would dictate
whether you get from here to there is
whether everything between
here and there is an improvement right
it you know it may be that there's an
opportunity in this room that would be
just
killer for a canary-like creature but
the problem is that you know for
you know if you bring you know i don't
know uh
ferrets in here and you breed them you
know can they detect the canary
opportunity enough that after
you know many uh millions of years that
they would be canary like probably not
because there's a lot of gobbledygook
between
ferret and canary so yeah so i mean the
the
go-to example is eyes right the eyes of
the complex
uh mollusks the cephalopods octopus and
squid are more efficiently built than
ours are
and we can imagine cheaper to run and
maybe better i don't know about the
better part but cheaper to run no blind
spot
and no blind spot right um but in order
for us to
have eyes as vertebrates like they have
we'd have to go through the adaptive
valley of having less and less and less
and less good vision
before we got to a spot where you could
rebuild uh you know build up something
from scratch i mean unless we start
forming eyes somewhere else on our body
and then you know having now a second
set of eyes can you know
disappear these but um to use the same
you know the same framework that is
already being used
you know be it locomotory or
cardiovascularly
or sensorily whatever it is you can't
take a selection
can't move you pure selection cannot
move you to a less fit state
so just to answer the
question finally imagine that you are a
rodent of a given size there is a
question
about whether or not scaled up by fifty
percent you'd be better off or worse off
right it might be that scaled up by 50
you'd be able to bite into some seeds
that you can't currently access because
they're too big to fit in your mouth or
your muscles aren't
um strong enough to crack them right so
there's an opportunity from being bigger
and then there's the cost of having to
fuel that larger body form
right now imagine if instead of random
mutation
figuring out whether or not it made
sense to be
50 bigger there was a
module that asked the question more
directly
right in other words in many in many
habitats
a mammal this size or a rodent the size
has been scaled up
successfully so can selection learn that
that's a question rather than have to
discover it each and every time
right that sort of thing very good
masked sneetches and sneetches without
meet the loyalty oath crusade
from um catch 22 which we read from
many episodes ago i would love a masked
mask and sneach shirt sold together or
similar malicious to tyranny compliance
merchandise
um yeah i thought i like that idea it's
cool and i've thought about sneetch
illustrations instantly we are still
looking through the artist submissions
uh thank you for those
um my concern is one of um copyright
honestly with snitches
um i just don't i haven't i haven't
looked into it but i'm sure that the
the seuss world uh has feelings about
whether or not people use
uh stitches on things um she's got her
head right under your okay it's not safe
um yeah no but i like the idea in
principle yeah um
so anyway yeah is it possible is the
question yeah
hey brett hi there do you have any
favorite
metal exercises i think that's going to
be mental but i'm going to leave it as
metal
do you have any favorite metal exercises
or introspective questions for while on
the herb
i know you don't smoke anymore but i can
imagine it affecting your thinking as it
has done to me maybe it doesn't mean
metal
yeah um yeah i mean you know basically
it's not worth doing exercises if they
ain't metal
that's my feeling um no mental exercise
sure i mean it's all mental exercises
every day
right and you know a lot of them aren't
conscious they're just ways
of looking at something and having an
intuition
of what might give way and figuring out
how
to um try it out
as if the thing had given way and seeing
what flows from it i i don't
know how to describe it but as i've said
uh
before we teach people how to do certain
things and
there's certain things that actually
can't be taught and
the how do you make
significant mental breakthroughs in a
field is one of these
can't be taught because even if you take
somebody who
does something and knows what they do
that method is very unlikely to work for
somebody else
it's not that there's no lesson in it
but um
but these things are deeply personal and
frankly
most of this comes down to motivation
that is to say you have to have a kind
of
perverse relationship with
frustration or
some kind of um
fruitless exploration is that you know
that
if you have the sense of like i have to
beat that puzzle i know it's beatable
and i have to beat it then you have to
have some sense of where to spend your
time
i think einstein has said some very
clever things about the
allocation of time to figuring out what
the question is relative to figuring out
um how it is answered but in any case
you have to have enough reward that you
actually
develop the capacity to do so i mean it
is an explorer mode question
yeah well i mean there's there's also i
feel like
i did this to some degree before we were
together but i i
really feel like you are one of the you
know maybe the master of this and i've
really
um come to recognize it as one of the
things that you do specifically
is um when
when assessing anything not that you are
observing directly so separate from you
go out and you observe a pattern and now
you're trying to figure out what the
question is but
when you are told something you
maybe start or at least very quickly get
to
what must be true if that is true what
is the foundation on which that claim is
built
and you try to trace all of them back
and
you know almost inevitably at least one
of the two things on which the claim
is built are at least a little shaky
right and you know very many of the
things that we believe to be true are
true
and the foundations on which they are
built turn out to be true even though
one or two of the
sort of like foundational pieces on
which they're built
aren't as easy to demonstrate as you
might like
but knowing exactly what it is
that your framework is built on so that
i mean in parts of so that so many
things but so that in part
um you are appropriately surprised when
it does or does not fail right later
you know oh well but i was told x okay
but also i had done all the analysis
going back to sort of
root situation and assessed that there
were some of the things
that were necessary to be true for that
to be true that i wasn't so sure about
and i mean i feel like you do this with
everything
well there and it's not i i say that um
and like that that is not
irritating to live with like that's not
an infuriating habit that's surprising
i know i know i think it would sound
like it was but at least for me it's not
well i i think you know in part there is
there's a part of this that depends
on a kind of concentrated
insensitivity to certain things even
just in yourself yeah
right and so just the simple discomfort
of thinking really ridiculous thoughts
like if you're somebody who as you start
thinking really ridiculous thoughts find
finds yourself uncomfortable like why am
i even allowing my brain
to play that game right if you do that
there's certain things you cannot find
right you will you will talk yourself
out of thinking the thought
whereas you know if you can which i mean
that is the game that the media is
playing with us
right around things like cover door gyms
like sorry
two origins like it it assumes that if
you tell people
often enough this thing is not worth
your consideration
you'd be crazy to think that thing most
people will go like okay
can't see that thing because i've been
totally crazy to think that thing right
and
then so you're right this is the right
thing the
shell game in that case the shell game
that comes from the implication
that for this virus to be unnatural as
those of us
who think lab leak is likely wonder if
it is
the implication is that it's some whole
other level of unnatural that we're
actually claiming which makes us sound
insane
right so we intuitively even those of us
who know very little about what goes on
in the lab
intuitively know that we are not in a
position to design a virus that's going
to go out and
infect people effectively right so the
point is if they can falsely portray us
as claiming that then we're easy to
dismiss because
people giving that thought the chance
just makes them feel
stupid right whereas you know biologists
who don't know how viruses work
using natural selection to solve
problems they can't yet solve
right that's a lot easier to imagine
right you know were the people who
you know turned bison-like creatures
into domestic
cattle you know expert geneticists
no no but they were gain of function
researchers they just didn't call
themselves that
right and they use the mechanism that
the fact is any reasonable person
you know could do just simply
recognizing that offspring tend to look
like their parents and therefore if you
want
offspring that look like that breed
parents that have produced those
offspring
etc etc so um i would like to ask you
though what the hell evolution has to do
with virology or epidemiology and why
you think you get to say anything in
this space
right yeah it is an amazing thing that
people don't recognize the ubiquity of
this level of analysis in all of the
questions that they're asking
right um
love the podcast can i get one of those
clubhouse invites
uh let's put it this way um we we should
distribute them there's no reason not to
so
as i acquire invites i am interested in
uh bringing people who want to make use
of them
in and i think you know the one thing i
can't really convey
is that the the thing is evolving and
the evolution
looks like conversation and for some
reason in the last
month all sorts of people that you
couldn't
hope to be in the same room with have
dropped in and had amazing conversations
and taking questions from the audience
and all of this so
there is a lot going on there so anyway
yes we will figure out how to get some
more
invites into the world could pro so i
just we have so many questions this time
and we're not going to get to the vast
majority of them so let's just try to
get through like
a few more really quickly here could
prolonged mask wearing lead to a more
fragile immune system in general beyond
just coven i'm thinking along the lines
of bubble boy
in contrast to how progressive exposure
to germs and allergens make it
antifragile
uh i really doubt it we responded to
this i think last week in the q a and i
couldn't point to exactly where
there's a level at which it will be true
it's not a level at which you should
avo avoid it you know so yeah and it
would be more true
if you like really locked yourself in
your house
and you live alone and you never go out
and you you know put
your groceries that are delivered
delivered to you in a
like airlock for a day before bringing
them in like you know every time you go
out
you get a little bit a tiny bit of
exposure to
something if you if you're just doing
your own grocery shopping or
occasionally
occasionally interacting with anyone but
in some sense
the hygiene hypothesis for allergies is
this taken to an extreme take into
account right so
if yes you know overly sanitize your
children's lives
you're likely to give them an allergy
rather than
prevent them from getting sick yep
true true i'm a disaffected lefty who
found you guys while wandering the
political wilderness
cool welcome uh when i heard about the
intellectual dark web i was turned off
by the label
idw has too many negative connotations
why don't you two come up with a new
name for our movement
uh well so eric weinstein brett's
brother who um
named it um did so with intention and
he's got a
good short video out on his channel eric
weinstein's youtube channel from
i don't know probably a year two two and
a half ago at this point
um explaining why he named it that um it
might it might morph into something
something different but yeah so i'm not
taking on a renaming campaign at this
point yeah it was uh
ironically named and in part because we
knew that we would be attacked to
certain things and so
uh you know stealing their fire by
labeling ourselves something absurd
was uh eric's intent yeah i wish my pro
uh profs were like you too if it were so
maybe i wouldn't have switched from
biology to math
and i learned more about how to think
from watching youtube videos than from
lectures
yeah unfortunately most lectures suck
that's part of why
since george floyd died my hospital does
daily moment of silence
quote to think about what we're doing
individually and collectively to fight
racial injustice
many ignore feel awkward get annoyed
what are your thoughts yeah i think it's
making things worse
yeah it's making these things making
things worse people are going to resent
it
and the fact is we should do a lot of
thinking about racial injustice and
especially
about the fact that a lot of it is
awfully subtle and doesn't function
through
the kind of bigotry that we're told is
everywhere
but making people do it is sure to
backfire
yeah taking people into a conscious
space and wasting a little bit of their
time every day
not going to be effective yep no way
um i don't know what this means
clubhouse is the front end of the ccp
company agora
yy be sure to enunciate your political
and financial plans clearly for the
translators
well i do think that there is a hazard
in here in that we don't know
you know as with all social media
networks we don't know
what is monitored and you know what it
would mean
for it to be banked i think we know that
they don't record the rooms
that is certainly what they tell us um
but um
i can't say more than that i can say
they are certainly going to have a data
problem uh
sorting through it but it would seem
again i've never been on it um but it
would seem
that at this point in our ability to
to do data collection um the collecting
text
written text is far easier than
collecting speech while turning it into
information
the problem as i
said to kim.com the other day on
clubhouse
is that banking the stuff even if you
don't know how to sort it allows for a
very surgical kind of
um repression because you if you bank
everybody's stuff and you don't figure
out how to analyze it through any sort
of
mechanism and then you only look at
those people
who have proven to be difficult you can
go back and you can understand
everything about their
lives back through whatever point you
started collecting
information so yeah i ain't saying it's
safe
given that men and women have different
evolved life objectives and men have
dominated politics until very recently
should women have our own party i mean
like a political party
if you mean political party if you mean
like a party
once again when we can have our own
parties when we have parties
i guess although i always like mixed sex
spaces more
um but our own political party no
no i i think um male typical ways of
getting things done in female typical
ways of getting things done
are both prone to go off to going off
the rails
in different ways and um the world is
all too familiar with the ways that male
typical ways of getting things done can
go off the rails because that has been
dominant politically
and female typical ways of getting
things done is going to go off the rails
in some other way
and we tend to see not heads of state so
much but
increasingly other organizations like
you know schools and such
um being led um by by women
and largely women's staff and you see
different kinds of errors
we need both we need there's a tension
between
and you know you can be a woman with
more male typical ways of leadership and
a man with more female typical ways of
leadership and all of that can be true
but we need both
to provide tension on on the other and
to keep the extremes from happening
what's more
i think we can probably come pretty
close to proving
that a woman-only political party
will not be viable and that the impact
of a non-viable
female-only political party will be to
empower its exact opposite
yeah um
thank you both for your great work it's
a refuge for many people for many
reasons
cool okay there's so many more questions
i'm going to just find two real quick
okay
um have you seen the video that majority
report did on you
no i have not um i don't actually know
what a majority report is
he who shall not be named okay
um
putting the thing in the mail is always
the hardest part isn't it i guess
hitting enter these days super chat in
solidarity with brett's psychic
discomfort heather's evident delight and
zachary's likely discomfort
um what do you guys think about the uf
meta study that came out showing that
pre slash asymptomatic spread has a
secondary attack rate of 0.7 percent
is coveted that different in terms of
asymptomatic spread compared to other
airborne viruses
but i just i don't know we spent a long
time
destroying i think um a study
from a few weeks ago on asymptomatic
spread
i don't know i don't know this is that
one i don't recognize that number that
number seems
wrong i don't i don't think i know this
particular study
um
i'm just looking for uh
could the characteristics of sarsko v2
give us clues to the environment that
the intermediary evolved
under very transmissible with inside
aerosols
trade off weak spread outside labs are
inside
so yeah yeah we've talked about this a
little bit too there's a lot there that
might be
the result of inadvertent selection in
the lab rather than
directed selection okay this seems like
a
two good questions to end on the last
two here i grew up in a young earth
creationist anti-vaxx household
i've had access to a computer in the
internet every day since i was 13
i'm 28 now i had to learn evolution from
the ground up
been following brett since 2014. thanks
for everything
cool cool yeah
one kev final question when cats cackle
at prey
could they be attempting echolocation
also
also second part of the question
consider that covid may have crossed
over in
batman in what batman
i don't know what that means like batman
exists does he not
i assume but therefore it's spillover
the spillover happened in the actual
hybrid individual that is
part man batman got it okay oh
absolutely um yes uh i think the only
argument against that
is that he's a fictional character i
feel like that
is a weak objection compared to
what is passing for evidence in a lot of
this space well
let us say that the evidence in favor of
the
batman intermediary hypothesis
is of similar strength to the evidence
in favor of the
frozen ferret badger stake hypothesis
yes yes yes yes okay when cats calculate
prey could they be attempting
echolocation
um i do not think so i don't think so
but that's cool
yeah i mean cats cats are so far well
let's see who
who's the closest relative to cats that
echo locates dolphins echolocate
cetaceans in carnival aren't that
closely related bats echolocate
chiroptera and carnival aren't that
closely related tenrecs
echolocate obviously uh these spiny
little critters in madagascar are
terrestrial
what are ten wrecks uh mammals well
insectivora is uh polyphyletic but they
are in the insectivore
i don't know where they are in the
mammal phylogeny compared to carnivorous
anyway like cats are cats are so
distantly related from anything extent
that echolocates
i can't is there anything in carnivora
that we know to echolocate
uh wait there there is um i believe
there is some
very weak evidence for some weak form of
echolocation
in seals yeah
but i'm not sure of that right but i i
think there is something but um anyway
it's pretty crude
um in any case
we wouldn't get there phylogenetically
is it possible that they would have
adapted such a thing sure but the point
is the cackles don't really
fit with the i mean a the things that
they would be
echolocating at the prayer to hear them
yeah um no it looks it looks more like
um they're trying to mimic something in
the
vocalizations or the interest space of
the would-be prey item
uh to get them either to come to or not
be scared by the
would-be predator i actually wonder you
know the thing about cats
is um many of their vocal vocalizations
domestic cats are targeted to humans
yeah and it is possible
you know things like per which is not
targeted inherently at humans
are there if you think about a purring
kitten a purring kitten is giving a kind
of information to its mother that
doesn't transmit very far
right so in other words it's not putting
the pair in danger in order to it's
conveying something without putting
something in danger right so it's sort
of like soda voce
communication and you might imagine
given that the relationship
of domestic cats to people is
hey you're gonna hunt little things that
i can't get my hands on
and i'll supplement your food right
that in such a relationship it might be
that a cat that can't get to an item out
there
is trying to send some sort of a message
i didn't know where you're going
okay so it might be communication too
it's a bone right like hey let me
i'm gonna go eat those right yeah um and
uh
anyway i will say that we have explained
this one
this is crazy
totally reliable if you open the
silverware drawer
such that the silverware which catches
the light from our
bad kitchen lighting and reflects it
back up onto the ceiling he
cackles at the reflections on the
ceiling
yeah that's crazy it's uh and you can do
it like
five six times at some point he tires
and he just sort of looks dejected
but yeah i keep expecting him to grow
out of it but he hasn't
yes it's amazing it's extraordinary yeah
and he doesn't really he doesn't
cackle through um glass doors at
critters outside he'll sometimes has to
go out but he doesn't actually
do it at the animals yep no it's the
silverware
yep all right well that was um that was
long
that was long that was long um we will
be back
we'll be back next week same time same
place
probably for a little less time i'm
thinking um
join brett on the discord tomorrow at 10
a.m
for an hour of conversation
um join us me at my patreon to get
access to the private q a
uh check out clips on the dark horse
clips channel join brett on his patreon
for monthly conversations and
be well be good to your people and
everyone else
eat well go outside all of it yeah all
that
i tell you what i will dig up another
invite and i will distribute it
to some deserving person on the discord
tomorrow somehow
um so uh anyway be well
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you